Hello to our friends and members of our
SumTV family. You're watching I'd like
to know our Bible question and answer
program. You send in the Bible-based
questions and by the grace of God, we
will give you Biblebased answers. Thank
you for joining us. My name is CA
Murray. To my left, Pastor David
Salazar. to my right, Pastor Steven
Boore. Uh, gentlemen, we greet you in
Jesus name. Amen. We get a chance to
study the word of God yet again.
>> Amen.
>> We want to encourage you to send in your
questions because we we love to get
them. And uh if the program simply
wouldn't be the same without your
questions. It's based on your questions.
Should you want to send in a question,
we invite you to do so by sending your
question to TV at sums as in marytv.org.
That's tvsumtv.org.
Send in your questions. We'll study and
give you the answer from the word of
God. We make that promise to you.
Pastor, would you open our program with
prayer and then we'll go on to our first
question.
>> Certainly. Let's pray. Uh thank you Lord
for allowing us to come to you through
prayer and to allowing us to be able to
be used by you. We pray Lord that in
this hour you will give us
understanding, wisdom and may we speak
according to your will so that our words
may encourage those who are watching to
grow closer to you to come closer to
your word and may understand uh clearly
more of what you have to say to our
lives. We thank you for your grace. We
pray this in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen and amen. Gentlemen, our first
question comes from Daniel
Mu Minua Mua from Nairobi, Kenya. I uh
have had the pleasure of visiting that
country. Uh the one time I was there
driving in from the airport in a taxi
where I could actually see the ground
through the bottom of the taxi uh from
in the cab. So it was a very harrowing
ride, but the people are very very
wonderful. Here is uh uh Daniel's
question to us. My name is Daniel uh an
Adventist writing from Naive Kenya
concerning verse 1 Timothy 5:22. So
who's going to turn for that? Who's got
that?
>> I have that.
>> You have that? Okay. Let me finish the
question. Do not be hasty and laying on
of hands. He says do not share in the
sins of others. Keep yourself pure. So
he's he's given that to us. I believe
that's from the New King James.
>> What does it mean? He is asking is Paul
admonishing Timothy not to be hasty in
praying for others? What does it mean to
share in the sins of others uh if not
plainly participating in them? I look
forward to your response.
>> All right. First of all, let's uh go to
the chapter that he's mentioning 1
Timothy 5:22. But um I think that it's
important to remind uh you know Daniel
and those who are watching that uh
taking a verse that is a little hard to
understand out of context is is is what
makes it complicated. But when you
actually read it in the context then
it's much more easier to understand what
it really is trying to say and what it's
not saying. So uh just for context I
want to mention to Daniel that since
verse 17 Paul is speaking in how to
organize the church and how to set up
rulers or elders rather for the church
service. And he mentions from verse 17
all the way to verse 21 what type of
elders they should be uh you know how
the elders should be elected and also
how to make sure that they are honorable
and and and what kind of characteristics
they should have uh and then I'm going
to read verse 20 21 um and 22 so that
you can actually get a better
understanding of what it means. It says
there in 1 Timothy 5:21 and 22, New King
James version of the Bible, it says,"I
charge you before God and the Lord Jesus
Christ and the elect angels that you
observe these things without prejudice,
doing nothing with partiality.
>> Do not lay hands on anyone hastily, nor
sharing others people's sins. Keep
yourself pure."
So in this particular experience, in
this particular uh setting, what Paul is
actually speaking of is in regards to
leadership. Amen.
>> And how he was not to just
>> hastily choose someone or because
somebody told him, hey, this is a great
person, you know, he should create a
great elder. Let's let's commission him
to the to the office. He's saying don't
do that because what if you elect
somebody that is not worthy or has not
proved himself in ministry then you are
responsible for his sins by hastily
moving on to electing somebody or
putting someone that is not really yet
matured or ready for such a position. So
in this particular verse, Paul is
basically telling Timothy, you can be
guilty of sins of those who you put that
are not ready for the mission for the
ministry. You have to be very careful
that you elect those who have already
proven themselves worthy and are ready
and are truly have been commissioned or
are called to become elders in the
church. So it's really about Timothy not
taking things hastily and not uh to have
[clears throat] not you know prove
someone that's worthy to for that
particular thing. And that's why he's
saying keep yourself pure. Don't
contaminate. He's not speaking of sexual
impurity in this particular case. For
example, he's speaking about don't
participate of politics. Don't allow
yourself to be uh given into uh you know
uh or or even not you know not you
sometimes in church can be that you
prefer this individual and people are
are are trying to elect somebody that
they like but it's not necessarily the
right approved. So he's saying don't get
yourselves involved in this kind of
things. Make sure that you select those
who have the spirit of God and who have
uh who fulfill the characteristics of a
elder for the church. So the context is
keeping uh the context is setting aside
individuals for service.
>> Yes.
>> And the the means mechanism you use to
do that
>> and uh it calls for us to be very
circumspect in our selecting of
individuals to examine their lives. Look
at the fruit. Don't just grab someone uh
and and make them a leader because your
fancy uh suits that or it is pleasing to
you. pastor,
>> if I can just read a couple of passages
from Paul, the qualifications of
overseers.
>> Um, they're called bishops also.
>> Um, this shows that there needs to be a
very careful examination.
>> Uh, it says in chapter 3 of 1 Timothy,
same book.
>> This is a faithful saying. If a man
desires the position of a bishop, he
desires a good work. A bishop then must
be blameless, the husband of one wife,
temperate, soberminded, of good
behavior, hospitable, a able to teach,
not given to whine, not violent, not
greedy for money, but gentle, not
quarrelome, not covetous, one who rules
his own house well, having his children
in submission with all reverence.
That's quite a list of qualifications.
Mhm.
>> It takes more than 5 minutes to to to to
see whether that person is qualified or
not. Also in the book of Titus uh uh we
find uh another list that is given here
>> in Titus uh chapter
uh 1 and verse five. It's talking about
elders now.
>> Yeah. It says, "For this reason I left
you in cree," talking about, he's
talking to Titus, "that you should set
in order," once again, church
organization. Yes. "Set in order the
things that are lacking, and appoint
elders in every city, as I commanded
you." And then it says, "If a man is
blameless, the husband of one wife,
[clears throat] having faithful
children, not accused of dissipation or
insubordination, for a bishop must be
blameless as a steward of God, not
self-willed, not quick-tempered, not
given to wine, not violent, not greedy
for money, but hospital, lover of what
is good, soberminded, just, holy,
self-controlled,
holding fast the faithful word, as he
has been taught, that he may be able by
sound doctrine both to exhort and
convict those who contradict. Now that's
quite a list of qualifications.
>> It takes a while to really examine the
individual. There has to be a trajectory
to examine the individual to see if the
individual is truly
>> fitting these criteria. And as you say,
that's exactly what Paul was talking
about in the verse that is referenced
here, 1 Timothy chapter 5 and verse 22.
>> Yeah. Um but if I could also add uh
something that is not in the question
and that is there should be a careful
exam of each baptismal candidate.
>> You know usually we have an evangelistic
crusade
>> and we baptize
>> 20 people come forward
>> and with maybe if not immediately within
a week we're baptizing them. [laughter]
You know, that's that's kind of like uh
expecting a baby to live as an adult.
>> There has to be an examination. And
we've really dropped the ball on that.
And what happens is we fill the church
with people that are going to cause
problems in the church because we have
not examined their life and their
knowledge of the doctrines of the Bible
to make sure that we're not introducing
um that we're not introducing uh into
the church individuals that are going to
be a detriment to the church.
>> Well said. We we're guilty of a bit of
mission creep, but since you open the
door uh we can walk through it uh
because it is a problem. The truth is,
gentlemen, and you both know this, you
you can't really make an Adventist in
two or three weeks.
>> No.
>> You know, you you can introduce them to
Adventism, but [clears throat] uh the
Adventist church, the Adventist
doctrine, as Adventists read, interpret,
and follow the Bible is not an easy
thing if you come from the world. And
also if you come from other religious
fraternities, we do things a little
differently. We we we hold strictly to
the Bible. If the Bible says do it, we
do it. If the Bible says don't do it, we
don't do it. And we don't fudge on that.
And if you are come from a a religious
group that is a little little more lazy
fair with the things of the Bible, this
is going to be tough. Uh or if you come
from the world and you're not used to
the self-discipline that is part of your
spiritual growth, it's going to be it's
going to be tough. So, we should not,
and I agree with you wholeheartedly, be
in in haste to get people into that
water because when they come up out of
the water, you want them to have some
sort of working relationship with Jesus
Christ. And you really can't do that
overnight. The thing is, you know, we
can be guilty by endorsing
somebody who has not been proven to be
ready for that office position in the
church or like you said pastor by
allowing individuals who are not ready
to be baptized to come to the church. So
>> we have to be careful to not be haste in
endorsing somebody and saying, you know
what, I I I think this person is ready.
make sure that that person is ready
whether it's for baptism or whether it's
for a position in the church. Uh just
give you an example that happened to my
father. My father was baptized
within two weeks since he met the
Adventist thing and he was given that
next Sunday five
you know uh duties in the church. He had
given you know
>> next Sunday or next Sabbath.
>> The next I mean the next day after the
baptism was on Sabbath. Okay. The next
day they elected him for five positions
in the church because he was you know a
individual who who was had some wealth
and he had education and and so they
thought oh this is this guy has to be in
this and this and that
>> you know way too young way I mean so I
can tell from experience it's not the
right approach you know you have to be
very careful because if you are
endorsing somebody and saying he's ready
or that person is ready and he's not you
are actually guilty of their sins, of
their mistakes. And this is what Paul is
actually speaking of here.
>> You know, I like to compare
u this issue of when people should join
the church
>> uh with the five stages
of preparation for evangelism,
>> right?
>> What are the five stages? Number one is
preparation.
>> Husband and wife have to plan. They say,
"Well, we're going to have children now.
We have the financial means." So, first
is planning. Okay. Mhm.
>> The second step is conception.
>> Yeah.
>> The third step is
birth.
>> Mhm.
>> Then you have next growth
>> which is
>> now here's my point. The reason I'm
mentioning this is because I think that
Adventist evangelism to a great degree
is deficient in two of the steps.
>> Yes.
first in the gestation se gestation
stage
>> the nine months
>> I have never seen a baby that is born
the first day that it's conceived
[laughter]
>> there has to be growth
before birth
>> absolutely
>> there has to be growth before baptism
>> that's one place where I think that
we're deficient in our evangelism we
don't allow the candidate
>> to grow in knowledge before they're
born, so to speak, in the baptistry.
>> The second stage
is growth
>> after birth,
>> once the baby is born.
>> Yes.
>> Because we say, "Okay, we got to go get
more babies now." And so, we ignore the
babies that were born,
>> leave them to fend for themselves.
>> We need to remember that they're babies.
>> Uh, and therefore, babies need care. you
know, babies uh need much more care than
a child has grown. Uh and many times we
simply uh want bunches of births and
we're not taking care of the babies that
have been born in the gospel. Mhm.
>> And and so I I think that in the area of
gestation, that is the period of growth
before birth and the baptistry and then
what happens afterwards, if we don't
care for them.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh they're going to die.
>> Yeah. So anyway, uh I I think that
that's related to this question because
this question is talking about,
>> you know, separating somebody for a task
in the church who is not ready and
baptizing someone who's not ready.
>> Not ready.
>> And I think that's why the Lord raised
this ministry pastor because of that
need, you know, to to grow, help not
only those who are learning about truth,
but also those who are after in the
church to grow. So I think this ministry
should be endorsed by all the churches
in in Adventism. You know they should
actually understand that we are here to
help motivate to help young people and
and well individuals grow to the
fullness of Christ.
>> They make they make stronger members.
What we do makes stronger members
>> Amen.
>> of the church.
>> Yeah. And it does take time to do that.
The world is moving so much faster. We
we think we have to move at the same
clip as well. When I gave my heart to
the Lord, they put me in the I can't
remember family lesson, Bible study
plan. I think it was 52 lessons. We were
in there for a year.
>> Amen.
>> That's the right way.
>> We in there for a year in that class.
>> Uh and I I I took my stand at 10:00 and
was baptized at 11. But
>> in from 10 to 11, there was a year of
Bible study. Every Sabbath, every
Sabbath afternoon, we're sitting out.
Now, you want to do it in like three
weeks, kind of have it your way. Burger
King kind of thing and it just doesn't
it doesn't work out.
>> It's because we want numbers.
>> Yeah.
>> We be we've got all caught up in wanting
to um be a church that has millions and
millions of members. But the big
question is are these really committed
members?
>> Are they members that are going to go
through the final crisis
>> because because they're strong in the
message?
>> Yeah.
>> You have to be strong in the message in
order to stand in what's coming.
>> Amen. And uh you know when
are babies sometimes born at the sixth
or seventh months?
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. But is that the ideal?
>> No.
>> Rushing them into being born? No. No.
No. No. Let them reach term.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> All right. Let's see if we can try to
squeeze just one more in coming from
Chris from Auckland, New Zealand. Very,
very nice.
>> Could I could I just Sorry about
interrupting. Could I just say one more
thing about the previous question? The
previous question has um what does it
mean to share in the sins of others if
not plainly participating in them?
>> I just want to read one verse. Sorry
about the interruption but I just have
to get this verse in.
uh Romans chapter 1
>> and verse 32
speaking about these certain individuals
who knowing the righteous judgment of
God that those who practice such things
are deserving of death
not only do the same but also approve of
those who practice them. Mhm.
>> So you're guilt you're guilty
not only if you practice the sins but if
you condone others who are practicing
them is what it's saying.
>> That's a very good point.
>> And so I had to get that verse in
because the question here is uh the
specific question is what does it mean
to share in the sins of others if not
plainly participating in them? God holds
you accountable just like the person who
committed the sin.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Yeah.
All right. Well done. Uh, Pastor Chris
Auckland, New Zealand heard a questional
explanation for what this means during a
Sabbath school lesson. So, we're looking
at Proverbs chapter 25 21- 22.
>> It deals with heaping burning coals.
Maybe you know something definite uh
fairly important as
it is a directive. All right. You want
to read that pastor?
>> Yes. I will read Proverbs 22 25.
Proverbs 25 21 and 22.
I'm reading from the King New King James
version of the Bible. It says, "If your
enemy is hungry, [snorts] give him bread
to eat. And if he's thirsty, give him
water to drink. For so you will heap
coals of fire on his head, and the Lord
will reward you." Mhm.
>> So here we have a verse that uh
particularly this uh concept of of what
he's asking the keep heap of burning
coals uh sometimes is not understood but
first of all let's look into what this
verse is actually trying to say. It's
the Lord is telling them specifically
that it's
important for us to with our enemies
with those who are against us that we
are to actually give them for their
needs. Instead of paying them with evil,
we repay them with good.
>> Correct?
>> We serve them. We love them. We showed
love. I mean Jesus even said that to you
know when he came to to this earth that
we're to love our enemies do to good
those who persecute you and you know and
speak evil of you. So here the principle
is love and serve and provide to the
needs of those who are against you and
the reason or or or or when you or the
result of that experience is that they
will have heapings or calls of fire on
his head. Now this does not mean that
you are trying to actually do some
secret revenge or that you are by doing
this you are being passive aggressive in
a punishment or that you are promoting
covert vengeance is not speaking of that
is actually using a Hebrew idiom to
understand that there is a burning shame
a piercing conviction a moral awakening
in their in in their in their lives and
I I'm going to kind of give an example
to to really make this point uh what
this means. If you go to the book of 1st
Samuel chapter 24 and uh I don't think I
have a time to read a lot of verses, but
if we go to 1st Samuel chapter 24, we
have the story of David that is being
persecuted by Saul, King Saul. And he uh
Saul has 3,000 of his best men trying to
find David. David has been, you know,
fleeing and and David has not done any
harm to Saul.
And as he comes into the to the cave to
to to rest or you know for a little bit,
David finds him there and instead of
David killing him or taking advantage of
situation, he shows mercy and kindness
and actually cuts the uh border of the
of his garment to eventually as Saul
left to prove to Saul that he did not
have any ill you know feelings towards
him that he actually respect expecting
him as the anointed of the Lord. And so
David comes out and speaks to him and
tells him, look, why are you listening
to those who are saying that I am have
something against you? I I I have been a
servant and you've been persecuting. And
so David is telling him publicly how he
is not doing him any harm. This actually
creates in Saul a reaction. Notice what
it says there in verse
uh
verse 16 and 17 again 1st Samuel 24:16-1
17 it says so it was when David had
finished speaking these words to Saul
that Saul said is this your voice my son
David and Saul lift up his voice and
wept then he said to David you are more
righteous than I am than I am than than
I for you have rewarded me with good
whereas I have rewarded you with evil.
evil. And so in this experience, we see
what this actual thought of burning
shame of or or or or burning coals mean
in his head. It's like he's being
convicted of his sin, of his wrongdoing.
And the Lord wants you to use this
opportunity to bring conviction to his
heart. And this is really what this to
me this verse means and what really uh
this concept of heap burning calls
uh conveys in this message.
>> The apostle Paul quoted this verse from
Proverbs. [clears throat]
>> Yes.
>> Uh whatever it means, it means that you
should not take revenge against people.
Yes. But you should be good to them.
>> Yes. Um it says in um Romans chapter uh
12 verse 19, "Beloved, do not avenge
yourselves, but rather give place to
wrath. For it is written, vengeance is
mine. I will repay, says the Lord.
Therefore, if your enemy is hungry, feed
him. If he is thirsty, give him drink.
For in so doing, you will heap coals of
fire on his head."
>> Amen.
>> And some people think that fire, of
course, a symbol of the Holy Spirit.
It'll bring conviction to that person
because you're being kind to them and as
a result you'll win a friend.
>> Amen.
>> That the text doesn't say that exactly
but that's uh what some person has
interpreted
>> in its greatest context. It's asking us
to be good all the time even in the face
of of opposition. Micah 6:8 do do justly
love mercy walk with God. Again our time
has slipped into eternity. We'll see you
again next time. Bye-bye. God bless.